mais c'est vrai que ça fait encore plus
flipper est-ce que on risque une trème
guerre mondiale là actuellement et
qu'est-ce qui ferait qu'on bascule dans
une trisème guerre mondiale Mo moi j'ai
tendance à être optimiste parce que je
pense que la situation est tellement
comment dire je je pense qu'en effet la
Russie est un la Russie est un élément
n'est pas l'élément déterminant dans ce
qui se passe notamment au Proche Orient
aujourd'hui ce qui se ferit ce qui fait
qu'on peut arriver vers une une trème
guerre mondiale c'est une forme
d'alignement des alliances et de
multiplication des force il y a 40 ans
je crois que c'était hier on a célébré
tristement l'attentat contre l'immeuble
de rakard où 48 58 parchutistes Français
avaient perdu leur vie c'était en 83 1
an après la création du Hezbollah à
l'époque le hzbollah était un groupe
donc activiste comment un groupe de
résistance à Israël qui occupait le
Liban sud le hzbollah est est devenu
aujourd'hui l'un des premiers groupes
armés internationaux c'est il a un
comment un pied en Irak il a une milice
s'appelle noujaba qui ce qui est
l'antenne du Hezbollah local en Irak il
aide les outils au Yémen tout ça sous la
férule de l'Iran avec notamment la force
quotes donc les les les les les Gardiens
de la Révolution et tous ces groupes par
rapport c'est pour ça que je dis c'était
il y a 40 ans par rapport il y a 40 ans
se sont considérablement renforcés
regardez les les les guerres qui a mené
Israël contre le Hamas c'était toujours
il y avait en gros Israël perdait
perdait comment un soldat pour 10
combattants pour il y avait 10
palestiniens tués pour un Israélien là
aujourd'hui on a eu une attaque
fulgurante inattendu du Hamas avec sans
doute desfillances de sécurité de la
part d'Israël qui vont être examiné plus
tard mais on a un nombre de morts
israéliens considérable et on a
découvert que le Hamas c'était
considérablement renforcé donc
aujourd'hui on a des acteurs de part et
d'autre c'est plus simplement des
groupes armés qui mènent des guerillas
ce sont de véritables groupes très
efficaces et qui peuvent éventuellement
infliger aux occidentaux ou à ce qu'on
appellera la la une forme de coalition
puisque maintenant il y en a une sur
place avec les Américains des des dégâts
considérables les pores-avions vous
savez les porte-avions américains mais
ils sont vulnérables au drones
aujourd'hui vous avez aujourd'hui on l'a
vu avec la guerre du
carabach l'armée de de de de l'Arménie
s'est fait décimer C T72 c'est c'est
avec les drones il il n'avait pas prévu
euh la parade donc aujourd'hui vous
pouvez être le faible dit le faible et
arriver à attaquer le fort et
aujourd'hui pour pour être assez clair
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer parce que
le danger vient d'où vient de l'Iran
est-ce que les États-Unis peuvent s'emer
on a vu on a vu même il aa dit hein la
Chine a misement des qui a intérêt à à
des enfin la vraie question là
aujourd'hui c'est qui a intérêt à ce que
le conflit dégénère euh il peut
dégénérer en effet vous avez dit un un
événement c'est ça le danger le danger
c'est que un un allié euh force les
autres à réagir et c'était ce qui
s'était passé hein souvenez-vous la
Première Guerre mondiale un obscur arch
archiduc qui meurt dans une ville sarevo
dont personne n'avait entendu parler le
nom et puis 4 semaines plus tard c'est
le plus grand conflit c'est le premier
conflit du 20e siècle et qui ou des
millions de personnes vont mourir donc
là on est dans une situation où je pense
très sincèrement niveau international
même s'il a la guerre en Ukraine il y a
quand même une volonté de maintenir le
conflit dans la région vous save parle
aussi de ce qui se passe en Israël en
Palestine mais bien sûr mais regardez
pour l'Ukraine l'Ukraine on a craint un
moment que le conflit allait déborder il
y avait eu ce fameux missile qui avait
atterri en Pologne vous aviez la
question de la
Moldavie on a réussi globalement
internationalement à circonscrire le
conflit à l'Ukraine c'est un conflit
encore très dur où il y a des centaines
de mort tous les jours mais c'est un
conflit propre entre l'Ukraine et la
Russie même si évidemment l'OTAN voilà
là je pense que la plupart des
dirigeants internationaux les Américains
et les Russes quelque part cherchent à
ce que le conflit n'aille pas au-delà de
la confrontation entre le Hamas et
Israël vous vous ne croyez pas ce qu'a
dit Elon Musk mais Elon Musk évidemment
il a il a repris la phrase d'ailleurs il
a dit slip walking c'est-à-dire il a dit
on y va comme des somnambules ce
qu'avait dit Henry guot au début de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est-à-dire
effectivement on peut sans s'en
apercevoir aller vers la guerre
maintenant je ne peux pas vous affirmer
et je j'ose espérer que une solution et
la paix va finir par par germ je sais
que ça paraît complètement naïf de dire
ça mais en tout cas que la paix armée
c'est c'est ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est qu'on se regarde chacun regarde
l'autre et cetera le hzbollah il faut
qu'il déclen si le hzbollah déclenche
quelque chose sur Israël au nord de la
frontière là ça risque d'être très
compliqué je pense que j'ai beaucoup
plus de crainte sur ce qui peut se
passer à la frontière nord d'Israël
d'ailleurs netanahou y était avec son
gilet par balle s'est fait filmer devant
les caméras hier parce que le Hezbollah
c'est le Hamas puissance 10 voilà Pierre
Martinet vouz je pense qu'on prend pas
en compte à suffisamment en compte
l'aspect idéologique de ce qui se passe
actuellement là-bas et au-delà d'une
seconde guerre mondiale ou une 3è guerre
mondiale pardon comme on a pu 4e oui une
4è ou une 5e enfin en 83 après après
après dracar puisque j'y étais il y a un
vieux libanais qui avait connu la
Seconde Guerre mondiale il m'a dit
écoute bien la troisème guerre mondiale
sera a déjà commencé sur le sol libanais
elle sera religieuse on prend pas assez
en compte ce qui se passe actuellement
la dimension la dimension idéologique ce
matin le président français a proposé
une coalition internationale pour
éérradiquer le Hamas hein pas pour
libérer les otages pour éradiquer le
Hamas donc ça voudrait dire quoi ça
voudrait dire qu'il il y aurait sur le
sol de Gaza des militaires français des
forces spéciales françaises américaines
euh allemandes britanniques c'est ce don
on pe c'est on pe les Français he on l'a
vu et ça ça pourrait déclencher des heur
intercommunautaires partout en Europe
vous avez vu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur les en Europe ça c'est un réel
danger parce que les heures
intercommunautaires ça peut ça peut ça
peut être que d hein ça peut être deux
trois personnes avec deux kalashnikov
mais après ça peut dégénérer et puis
peut-être pas un conflit mondial mais
européen avec avec des des des poches de
de de guerrias civil en Europe parce que
le conflit qu'on le veille ou non il a
apporté en Europe depuis de nombreuses
années alors oui justement idéologie
c'est extrêmement important et
éventuellement cette guerre de de de
religion parce que encore un truc vous
allez me dire encore il fait peur le le
pape russe patriarche Cyril il nous dit
saint Séraphin de Sarov a permis à la
Russie d'obtenir la l'arme nucléaire
c'est béni de Dieu mais attendez le pape
le patriarche des orthodoxes nous parle
des armes nucléaires comme un cadeau
de Dieu pour la Russie cétait surtout
sacarof
quoi vous voyez vous voyez ça ça peut
mener il y a Simonian vous savez la la
directrice de Rach today qui a dit qui a
sorti un truc il faut prendre une énorme
bombe H de plusieurs mégatonnes et la
faire péter sur la Sibérie 100 km dessus
de la
Sibérie comme ça toutes
les tous les T portable tous les
ordinateurs sont sont tués ça ne va pas
faire de dégâts en Sibérie ça a causé
à de l'autre côté côté américain vous
avez Linz grraham qui qui demande
d'attaquer l'Iran en fait vous avez des
dingot un peu
partout on va se retrouver dans un
instant on va se retrouver dans un
instant on reparlera de ce que vous avez
dit sur Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on va
voir ce qu'il a dit puis on aura les
images incroyables de cambrioleurs
déguisés en faux livreur qui svissent en
France vous allez voir faites très très
très attention vous allez voir ces
images sont incroyables et c'est un vrai
gang GL ça c'est vie de plus en plus
très très violent vous allez voir ça
dans un instant à tout de suite